hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem setup video so viele leute haben
sich das einmal gewünscht dass ich
einfach mal aufnehmen wie ich halt
aufnehme aber mehr oder weniger so nenne
ich lade das jetzt auch übrigens grad
nicht auf lukas filmt also nicht auf
meinem reallife kanal hoch den ihr hier
findet hier ist ein link zu meinem
reallife kanal da könnte einfach hin
klicken dann lade ich mir live sache nur
noch hoch weil das die zeit einfach
gaming bezogen deswegen dachte ich das
kann ich meine dorf computer hochladen
und ich ganz einfach alle sachen durch
die ich hier so besitze die ihr euch
dann eventuell auch kaufen können wobei
mir alles läuft und alles perfekt und
ich hoffe ich mache keine fehler ich
schreibe ich auch noch mal die ganzen
sachen die ich habe in die kommentare
also nicht die kommentare sondern in die
beschreibung natürlich ich bin ja
youtube erfahren
ich habe übrigens gerade vorhänge vor
mein zimmer gezogen eine room to werde
ich erstmal nicht umgezogen bin übrigens
auch heute gar nicht fragen
ihr könnt schon fragen damit man sehr
was von interesse da ist wenn ich
umgezogen bin ob ich dann eine mache
aber egal ich würde angefangen direkt an
mit diesem wunderschönen mikrofon hier
das ist ein arbeitskampf die manuelle
manuellen hier sei hier das ist ein
wunderschönes nah kann man es lesen ein
wunderschönes rote einen roten t1 ist
das und zwar ist das ein großer membran
membran mikrofon
so jetzt geschafft so sieht das aus ich
habe die spinne also den kopfschutz hier
bobs schützen
das habe ich nicht so sondern habe ich
immer so damit ich mir was da durch
kriege finde ich wirkt andere meinen das
bringt gar nix also ich für meine sache
kann sagen dass es was bringt
hier habe ich das halt drin ich habe
dieses paket genommen für 150 euro oder
keine anbieters weil hier halt mit
dieser spinne drin world alles dabei war
spinne pop shop mikrofon aber nicht
dabei aber xlr gabionen müsst ihr da
reinstecken
danach ergaben geht hier durch meinen
mikrofonarm von welcher marke des weise
nicht da könnt ihr packe ich euch eine
beschreibung der koste nicht viel 640
oder so denn das hat ganz gut weil das
kann ich hier an meinem tisch befestigen
dann geht er hier so hoch ich zeig euch
das mal so und den kann ich dann halt
hier einfach so moment noch mal kann ich
halt hier einfach so hoch liegen und so
der website stehen wenn ich da mal nicht
aufnehmen will kann ich ihn halt einfach
so machen dann wird auch da stehen
dass ich sehr kabel geht halt dadurch
durch die mikrofonarm das wird dann hier
irgendwie so gebündelt keine ahnung wie
ich das damals gemacht habe irgendwie
das alles und dann geht das ganze hier
in meinem spiel drei das ist ein moment
da ist dass gerade das kabel für zu hoch
mit dem etwas des vereins ist es ist ein
behringer 10x 1002 ihr müsst dann das
xlr kabel hält nur da rein tun oder in
die ganze linke seite oder die zweite
von links
dann könnte ja die ganzen einstellung
vornehmen könnt ihr von mir aus von mir
kopieren aber das komplett auf eure
stimme auch ein bisschen drauf an
so sieht das halt bei mir aus könnt ihr
halt alles ein bisschen variieren ich
bin dort mit dem sohn bisher mit dem
focus ein bisschen umstellen möchte dass
er gerade auf manuell ab nämlich jetzt
ein paar sachen sondern ständig wechseln
kann
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel mal hier
einbrecher seht ihr da dieses grüne h
da steht zum beispiel aus das ist immer
ganz guter weg ihr ob ihr was ihr von b
gehabt da also bin ich auf jeden fall
sehr zufrieden mit dem mischpult eine
gute preisklasse und ja dann kommen
jetzt meiner softbox es ist eine light
light box softbox als sie als nächsten
in der beschreibung völlig gegenhalten
irgendwas falsch
falls mein gott falls ich irgendwas
falsch sagen die linken in der
beschreibung ist ganz gut da kann ich
hier machen machen das ist extrem jetzt
mal aus einfach ja das ist halt meine
softbox dies halt auch da unten ist mein
ganzes kabelgewirr
wenn ich mal so zeigen da sind die
ganzen stecker drin und verwunden und da
hinter dem vorhang sind auch noch welche
und eigentlich habe ich die vor allem
auf aber ich werde nicht zu viel von
meinem garten zeigen und alles schon
blabla spiegel ich mich dann ja dann
komme ich zu meinem pc ja schon erkannt
es ist ein 115 gerade weil ich weiß
nicht ich das drehen soll
so sitze ich halt immer hier vor
und hier liegen hier halt so meine hand
das ist das ganze ich fange es mal mit
der tastatur an dass eine roccat isku
habe ich jetzt auch schon seit zwei
jahren glaube ich mittlerweile schon ist
auf jeden fall heftig lange nicht ran
funktionierte doch da seht ihr es auch
schon sehr sehr abgenutzt der
verstaubten nutzt sie gar keine special
hotkeys oder sony gibt sich am rand und
da unten auch witzig gar nicht aber ich
finds halt gut dass hier auf dem mwc ist
hier mal erkennt da ist zum beispiel
sonne sonne riffel taste und hier auf
dem f auch und auf dem j also wenn man
zockt oder so wenn minecraft spielt kann
ich immer hier so fühlen so aber weder
so einen rüffel taste das ganz gut
und ja das ist halt meine tastatur die
rocket ist kann ich euch nur empfehlen
ich bin übrigens kein partner von
irgendeinem unternehme ich kaufen da
schon noch alles selbst dann habe ich
hier als maus die razer mamba kann ich
auch jedem nur empfehlen das einzig
blödes halt dass dieses ding hier dieses
dings kleber geht manchmal ein bisschen
ab und dies ist eigentlich ne maus wo
ich das hier ab machen kann
aber ich finde die reagiert halt viel
besser wenn die am kabel ist immer da
stört mich jetzt auch nicht nur das
kabel sei halt mit einer schlaufe drin
und immer wenn ich dann zum beispiel
dass der mensch stuhl übrigens grad da
sich lauf und wenn ich mal einen fuß auf
streckt sich das dann so runter dass zum
beispiel komisch erstellt die festhält
mind epic
naja mein pc mac von apple richtet mich
alle ich bin damit auf langsam nicht
mehr zufrieden mit meinem computer weit
von der leistung echte ist 23 jahre alt
ich habe eine laptop grafikkarten von
radeon das sind die ganz schlecht
laptops haben wenn ich mit schildern
spiel habe ich 5 fps
also läuft nicht so gut und internet 16
kader kommt eine ganz schlechte kombi
zustande
ich muss aufpassen dass ich jetzt
irgendwas zeige was er noch nicht sehen
sollte auch hier ist gerade frau doch
falsch aufgenommen
sogar mal mit face camp kommt jetzt eine
neue staffel hier ist gerade die wurst
folge auf meinem real life kanal die
sogar heute noch online gekommen ist die
müsste schon online sein
hier ich gebe euch mal ein kleines sneak
peek da sind menschen der schwebebahn
festgesteckt und der bäcker gegen woche
streit becker gegen pocher steht kommt
ins fernsehen
naja egal dass so manch mit notizen das
ist mein
cc mit meinem wunderschönen windows
design ich liebe dieses design irgendwie
das nicht irgendwie weiß nicht das sieht
cool aus als normales kinder ich freue
mich vom projekt cool aus na gut das ist
halt mein erster bildschirm
das ist mein zweiter bildschirm das ist
ein samsung syncmaster es 22 b 350 ist
ein bisschen kleiner seht ihr schon aber
es ist ja ganz cool weil da kann ich
hier wenn ihr seht ihr die maus sieht
man auf dem video hier sieht man die
maus kann ich hier zum beispiel
vorübergehen
es war ein bisschen versetzt zu aber mir
ist es relativ egal ich mache ich pack
meistens wenn ich irgendwie überarbeitet
packe ich die ganzen sachen die ich fürs
video bearbeiten brauche darüber damit
ich das dann halt so sehen kann so
welche sachen nicht also noch so rein
ziehen sollte und so was alles also dass
meine beiden bildschirme
dann habe ich hier noch eine microsoft
hd 5000 heißt die glaube ich hallo
fokussiert durch mal bitter und ich
sollte vielleicht mal so fühlen dann
seht ihr das besser hd 5000 heißt die
filmt finde ich scheiße ich habe mir
eventuell die bessere variante holen
weil die dna glaube ich auch hat die ist
nicht so toll die habe das auch als sind
wir nicht so mit zufrieden seht ihr
selbst ich versuche mal das beste
rauszuholen aber ich denke lieber die
face kam es gar keine facebook
das ist halt meine face cam wie gesagt
ich könnte euch noch zeigen alle di luca
film schauen und jetzt hier sich das
video angucken das ist meine stadt ist
voll geil weil man kann das einmal hier
so ausfahren und dann nochmal da unten
also ich denke kann sich das vorstellen
ist das halt so einen fetten pyramide
und ihr könnt das nochmal hier
hochziehen ich habe hier leider dieses
ding hier abgerissen moment das hier
habe ich abgerissen und sex rechner
hier kommen jetzt fokussiert dich da da
sieht man dass ich halt abgerissen das
sollte eigentlich ein hebel dran sein
allerdings geht das damit halt hoch und
das geht auch noch x 50 cm nach oben
darstellt das meistens dann einfach hier
drauf auf meinen tisch und dann hab ich
das halt ich auf einem tischchen stehen
und dann habe ich das licht an und
stelle ich mich meistens da so hin wo es
gab einen stuhl steht und ein hotel
also das ist dass comex 190 oder
kuhlmann primax 190 meine kamera ist
eine canon eos 600d mit einem tief aber
ich glaube da rauf bis 135 objektiv und
mit dem rohde video mac pro wie gesagt
links sind in dem description denn sonst
habe ich eigentlich gar nichts mehr ich
hatte man logitech g35 noch ach so
kopfhörer
das war könnten bewegt dass mein
kopfhörer sein apple kopfhörer von
meinem iphone ja sonst war's das mit
meinem setup ich hoffe euch hals
gefallen wollt ihr mehr so spontane
videos nicht einfach so machen
dann schreibt man in den kommentaren und
dann würde ich fragen mikrofon kamera
drin fällt mir dazu ein mit uns beim
nächsten mal